هنا
[موسيقى]
نحن الضحايا هنا ،
نحن
ضحايا كيان جشع للغاية ،
لقد صدمت من الطريقة التي يعاملنا بها الأشخاص الذين
كنا نتعامل معهم ، ولا
أستطيع أن أصدق ذلك بصراحة تامة
[موسيقى]
أجنبية
كيف يتذرعون بالفقر بأنهم
يخسرون الأموال يسارًا ويمينًا عندما يمنحون
مئات الملايين من الدولارات لرؤسائهم
التنفيذيين ،
فمن العار المثير للاشمئزاز عليهم أنهم
يقفون في الجانب الخطأ من التاريخ
في هذه اللحظة بالذات ،
نحن عمالة ونقف شامخين و
نطالب بالاحترام والتكريم
لمساهمتنا ، فأنت تشارك الثروة
لأنك لا تستطيع أن تعيش بدوننا إنها
لحظة حرجة في حياة
الصناعة ليس فقط للممثلين ولكن
لكل شخص آخر وكل موجات
الصناعة التي سيؤثر عليها هذا  إذا
كانت ستنجح على الإطلاق ، فعلينا أن تكون
أنت تعرف جزءًا منها
[موسيقى]
أجنبية